husband hotel is just one heck of a show
right i mean in one episode
the one episode in existence you have a
killer premise
unbelievable animation sharp writing
catchy musical numbers
and amazing characters to boot i mean in
just 30 minutes the pilot alone
has more content than whole seasons of
other shows but before i get into the
meat and potatoes of today's theory i
wanted to start things off with
a mini theory ready for this in the show
we're introduced to what is currently my
favorite character
alistair the radio demon an all-powerful
being who we're told
just appeared in the underworld one day
alistair manifested in hell
seemingly overnight and from there he
just wrecked house
showing power and control in a way that
no one ever had as they described it in
the show
many have speculated what unimaginable
force enabled him
to rival our world's most ancient and
destructive evils
well friends my mini theory is that
alistair the radio demon gets his powers
from none other
than gravity falls his own bill cipher
now let me be perfectly clear on this i
know this isn't true
but the similarities between the two
characters are uncanny i mean alistar's
microphone
is alive it also has that one-eyed thing
going for it just like everyone's
favorite equilateral lad
bill both bill and alistair trick into
making deals that you're gonna go on to
regret
both ominously glow when they're making
said deals and the deals of both are
seemingly
sealed with a handshake both are closely
associated with mysterious
runic symbols that fly in and around
them both also seem motivated by the
same thing
boredom and a large desire to use their
powers to create chaos for
really no good reason but all of that's
superficial right it's all
typical deal with the devil business no
it's the whole radio demon thing that
gets me
alistar's voice in has been hotel sounds
like an old-timey radio which is cool
it's very creative characterization but
it also just
feels random too random they even show
an example of the types of radios that
he broadcasts on and they're the type
that are pulled straight out of the late
30s and early 40s now
why would i care about that well bill
cipher is most closely associated with
one
particular song we'll meet again a love
song that was made popular by the singer
vera lin it's a great song
all-time classic but why i bring it up
here is that it was first made famous
during world war ii which wouldn't you
know it just so happened
to be during the late 30s and early 40s
the exact time that alistair's voice is
drawn from
the timeline matches up so could it be
that the reason alistair is so powerful
when he first enters the underworld is
that he has the powers of bill
cipher on his side probably not probably
just inspiration the creator of the
series got from gravity falls still
it is my personal head cannon for now
but hey
that's just a theory a film
theory and look the episode hasn't even
started yet
hello internet welcome to film theory
where we'll meet again
do nowhere do no win it'll be one week
from today when we have another upload
hence why you should subscribe in the
next five seconds
by the way while you're down there
crucifying the subscribe button leave a
comment
are you a gravity falls fan and if you
are who is your favorite character
just curious if that whole mini theory
at the top of the episode went over
everyone's head it'd be pretty
awesome to see bill show up somewhere
else one of these days something tells
me
not a show where one of the main
characters is named after a drug then
again he did show up in a
i believe an official rick and morty
short didn't he so
stranger things have happened anyway you
know what they say the devil's in the
details
that's not the only place he is wanda
vision get out of this theory you're
done you are done we've dedicated enough
theories to you get out of here anyway
today we're gonna be looking into a
project that a lot of you have been
asking me to do for quite some time
has-been hotel this dark and very adult
comedy aired its pilot episode on
youtube back in october of 2019
before eventually being picked up to
become a full run show in august of
2020. so i was kind of holding off until
we heard about a release date or more
news but sadly there's been nothing
since
hopefully we'll find out more soon
because there are all kinds of juicy
weird things going on in this world that
i want to go
theory sicko mode on but can't because
there's only one episode in two short
webcomics i would have just left it
alone but
after has been sister series heck of a
boss
included freaky animatronics i knew it
was my time creepy animatronics not
gonna brag
but uh they're kind of my bat signal so
we'll save the juicy lore mysteries for
when there's you know a bit more
lore in the series to analyze instead
what i want to focus on today is the
core premise behind the show the main
conceit of has been hotel is that
there's limited room in hades for souls
and the place is currently full to the
brim
resulting in an annual purge event they
call the cleanse
we lost so many souls and it breaks my
heart to see my people being slaughtered
every year
our protagonist charlie princess of heck
hopes that as an alternative to
cleansing each year she can instead run
a hotel that rehabilitates wayward souls
so they get sent off to the good place
where
obviously they'll meet ted danson and
eat froyo so
i've been thinking isn't there a more
humane way to hinder overpopulation here
in hell
perhaps we can create an alternative way
to change souls through
redemption and despite the fact that
pretty much every character doubts that
she can do it well gosh darn it her and
her ragtag
band are gonna try and of course sing
plenty of musical numbers along the way
but the question i want to know what i
need to solve as we wait for any news
about this series
is what she has to do to make a
difference like if her goal is to
replace the cleanse by rehabilitating
enough souls to clear out room and hack
how many souls are we talking about here
how big does this hotel have to be
just how outlandish are charlie's plans
long story short when the population of
hades is bursting
what is it gonna take to reach an
equilibrium perfectly balanced
as all things should be that's right
theorists today we're pulling a classic
reverse thanos by balancing the
population
except this time everyone's already dead
so let's start by outlining this crazy
universe between the two shows helmed by
creator vivziepop we've been told
a lot about the machinations of this
underworld we learn from the opening
song of hell of a boss episode 2 that
there are
seven rings in heck similar to the
layout of dante's inferno
minus two
[Music]
there might have been nine at one point
as the nine
circles are referenced in the pilot
episode of has been what
in the nine circles makes you think a
single
denizen of hell would give two facts
about becoming a better person
but since then apparently it's collapsed
back down to seven with each being named
after one of the seven deadly sins
however despite there being a bunch of
ringed layers attack on titan style only
the top ring the pride ring matters for
our calculations today
you see according to this official post
on twitter quote dead sinners can
only exist on the top ring pride other
rings house native-born demons and human
souls aren't allowed to travel between
the rings oh and uh canadians
are kept elsewhere because of reasons
there's a town for the canadians in hell
it's it's just little canada
it's the canadian part of hell is just
called heck it's just
don't you love it when lore is made up
on the fly during a live stream
now as i mentioned earlier because space
and heck is so limited
each year exorcists sent from heaven are
tasked with wiping out enough souls to
make room for next year's sinners and
maybe that'll be fodder for a new theory
after we get some more episodes wait
would that make me double dead so how
many souls is charlie going to have to
redeem each year to keep the population
of the necropolis from swelling too high
well funny enough the problem is a bit
simpler than it might first appear
we actually don't need to know the size
of pentagram city or the pride ring or
do
things like we did during our attack on
titan theory where we measured ring
population density and all that because
this time we are told explicitly that
the city is at capacity and that the
yearly cleansing is to knock that number
back down that means we
only need to be focused on the rate of
new souls entering their unhappy
afterlives
if at the end of the year the underworld
is winding up at capacity well
charlie would need to redeem as many
souls as would wind up down there in
order to maintain an equilibrium and the
good news for charlie is that the rate
of souls going into the afterlife
is starting to stabilize the past 150
years or so has been
absolutely wild for the growth of the
human population in 1900 there were
about 1.6 billion people on planet earth
and just
a hundred years later in the year 2000
that number had reached
6 billion fast forward another 20 years
to today and we're at 7.8 billion people
luckily for everyone and everything on
planet earth that number is no longer
increasing at anywhere near the same
rate it was back then
humanity's growth rate is slowing and
for more on why that's happening you can
actually check out our classic episode
about why
thanos's plan in infinity war isn't as
crazy as it might initially sound
long story short people are investing
more time into their children and are
thus having fewer of them
causing the population to overall level
out sociologists have made various
estimates about where the population
will eventually max out but reasonable
guesses put the total somewhere between
10 and 12 billion people certainly a lot
but also
not super far off from where we are
right now the death rate is
also constantly fluctuating but has in
general been falling for the past
century in fact it's thought that the
death rate actually
bottomed out in 2018. projections made
by the united nations already estimate
that death rates will begin rising again
over the next few decades as the
population begins to age and as
demographic shifts towards poorer
countries put a larger share of the
population in situations with worse
medical conditions but 2018's global
death rate was 7.546
deaths for every thousand people with a
global population of 7.58 billion
in 2018 that would mean that roughly
57.2
million people died in that single year
but of course not all of those people
are going down below
if you know what i mean only the sinners
are now in the show we see depictions of
all sorts of sinful activities
everything from murder to the usage of
illicit substances
so one way to solve our problem would be
to take that group of 57 million deaths
and figure out what percent of them have
engaged in one
or multiple of the damning activities
that we see happening
in and around pentagram city according
to data from the 2016 world
drug report there were 247 million
illicit substance users worldwide in
that year alone which is roughly three
percent of the global population and
when i say they're using the stuff i
mean that they're using the hard stuff
the stuff i can't say on youtube for
fear of this video getting even more
risk of demonetization than it already
has
so right off the bat that three percent
translates to 1.7
million people sent to the deep depths
below
off of drug use alone homicides are
thankfully significantly less with an
average of seven homicides for every
hundred thousand people globally
if we assume that each one of those
homicides is being committed by a
separate person which
obviously isn't true but is going to
give us our worst case scenario that
adds another
530 000 new additions to our hotel guest
list
that number is very concerning when you
think about what it represents
the number of murderers on this planet
is too darn high for other violent
crimes the average is actually a bit
higher
12.7 per hundred thousand people
globally boosting us by another 962
660 souls so after the substances and
horrific
violence section of our program today
we're walking around with a pretty
sizable hotel
already 3.2 million souls
all needing to be redeemed if heck is
going to maintain some level of
population equilibrium
eat your heart out paris hilton princess
charlie has got your hotel chain
beasted see that joke's relevant because
paris hilton is super famous for being
rich and having a bunch of hotel barons
in her family but the joke
isn't all that far off from reality as
of last year marriott hotels is the
world's number one hotel chain with
nearly
1.4 million rooms available for their
guests worldwide
charlie's happy hotel already needs more
than double that amount and we are
still not done counting sins my friends
because it's this last one where the
numbers really start to skyrocket
infidelity cheating in relationships now
while i'm not promoting religion here or
anything and we all know that different
religions can have some major
differences one
thing that they all tend to agree on is
that you're not supposed to be
you know coveting your neighbor's wife
and all that but despite those warnings
humanity certainly seems to be doing a
lot of coveting these days
according to an exhaustive review of
research done on committed relationships
published back in 2005
40 of unmarried relationships and 25
of marriages see at least one incident
of infidelity another survey
roughly backs this up 20 of men and 13
of women admit to having a fling with
someone other than their spouse while
married so
i'm gonna split the difference here and
say that i don't know roughly 30 percent
of people are skeez balls who have
cheated at some point in their life
y'all suck as someone who has cheated on
in the past i hope the radio demon eats
your heads off and it looks like he's
gonna have plenty to feast on because
that suddenly jumps us up by get this
another 17.3 million
sinners sending our grand total to 20.5
million
new center denisons of pentagram city
waiting to get purged
each and every year requiring the single
biggest rehabilitation initiative you
could ever need
might want to consider getting more help
for that front desk there charlie now
obviously a lot of these people might be
overlapping in their sins right not all
of these are mutually exclusive to each
other so maybe i'm going about this all
wrong
maybe this isn't about me judging other
people based on their sin totals maybe
the difference between heaven and heck
is like those stupid reviews that you
have to do at your job
a self review assess yourself for how
well you're doing at your job
i mean why is this a thing like this
drove me
nuts when i was working in an office
environment and even today working on
youtube yes thank you i'm doing
fantastic look today alone i dredged up
stats about infidelity and illegal usage
of mind-altering substances
i am crushing it that was your day but
seriously guys some of you missed the
memo about always giving yourself a good
review because when people were asked to
self-report about whether they would go
to heaven or to the other place
10 of people said that they were
definitely going
to the bad place no ifs ands or buts
about it
another 42 said that they weren't sure
and if they're not sure well pretty sure
st
peter at the pearly gates ain't gonna be
giving you the benefit of the doubt
by those numbers that 20.5 million souls
was an
understatement now we're talking closer
to the range of
30 million hold on though what about
friends raiding their friends well when
asked
72 americans who believe in heaven rate
their chances of going to heaven to be
good or excellent all right doing a
little bit better on that one america
but they also turned around and said
that one
in four of their friends would
absolutely go to h double hockey sticks
way to throw your friends
under the bus there guys in short anyway
you're calculating this there is no way
that charlie's hotel accomplishes its
true mission in under
14 million souls oh sure she can save a
few wayward souls here and a few demons
there but if she's
truly looking to break even 14 million
is the minimal calculation based on all
the different methods that we just tried
and there's someone else working against
her in this whole process too
the real twist hiding at the end of both
of these shows is that the immediate
murder patrol
imp imp the organization that we follow
in the sister show hell of a boss is
gonna be
working directly against charlie and her
goals
the imp is powered by a grim war that
they stole from a demon named
solace in his very first appearance
solace asks the imp team to kill someone
who's spreading the truth about global
warming hoping to increase that death
rate we were talking about earlier
he's trying to convince people global
warming exists
doesn't it well yes but more people die
if nothing is done about it
solace is specifically trying to
increase the population of souls despite
already existing overcrowding it's
almost like the two shows are working
directly against each other one is about
souls getting out of heck
the other is about souls getting in so
will charlie manage to create a system
that's capable of saving some 14 million
people or more a year
or will the native demon's plans
ultimately stop her
it's honestly a fascinating dichotomy
because the two shows are so clearly
poised to clash against each other
either side could end up the victor and
while charlie may seem the more
traditional protagonist to end up
winning the day
these shows are anything but traditional
so i guess we'll just have to wait to
see what creator vivziepop has in store
for us when the full show
eventually drops but until then it's all
just a theory
a film theory and before you
check out for the week let's give a big
thank you to today's sponsor
the world's premier streaming service
for horror thriller and supernatural
content
shutter much like has been hotel shutter
is filled with countless dead souls of
the most despicable variety
gotta admit charlie would have one heck
of a time trying to redeem some of these
guys but hey that's what makes horror
films so great right the worst the
villain the more exciting the movie and
with shutter you get access to all the
most exciting
horror supernatural and thriller movies
out there the
largest collection of acclaimed horror
movies and series streamed right to your
favorite devices for just
5.99 a month we're talking access to
their unique collection of exclusive
and original films series and classics
all ad-free and new titles are being
added weekly
both old classics like the nicholas cage
cult movie vampires kiss from 1989
and new favorites such as the golden
globe nominated film for best foreign
language film la yorona both of which we
watched last month vampire's kiss was
actually my choice for valentine's day
date night and
i may or may not have been misled by the
title steph on the other hand shows la
yorona for us to watch last week because
she had heard such good things one of us
clearly has more refined taste if you're
not familiar with it la jorona blends
together the terror of both myth
and reality into a devastating expose of
the genocidal atrocities against the
mayan community in guatemala it won best
film at the 2019 venice film festival
and was an official selection to
sundance 2020. it is not a lighthearted
romp through the roses my friends but i
can say that it is a great movie that i
highly recommend you check out when
you're in the right mood for that sort
of thing let me just say we did not
choose to watch that one on valentine's
day and uh probably a good decision
anyway that's just a small selection of
what shutter has to offer so go and take
a look for yourself i am positive that
there is gonna be a bunch on there that
you're gonna absolutely love
all you need to do to try shutter for
free for 30 days is go to shutter.com
that's s-h-u-d-d-e-r as in
i've got a cold chill down my back
shutter not i'm gonna shut the windows
with my shutters and then make sure you
use the promo code
film theory on your way out that's
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-y
film theory you will not be disappointed
you will be shaken and a little bit
scared
perhaps you will have peed yourself a
little bit but you will not be
disappointed
honestly after watching shutter for the
past few months i've had to add a few
more lights to my recording closet fun
fact i used to record all my audio just
from the light of my phone screen yeah
not anymore thanks a lot for that one
shutter we're talking tanning bed levels
of illumination happening in here anyway
go check it out only 5.99 a month for
countless hours of horror now if you'll
excuse me i need to go check out yet
another nicholas cage movie for an
upcoming theory
and in the meantime i'll see you all
next week